welcome to Haris hobbies the chana where
we discussed the latest tech news and
dove into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at the truth behind
the GTX 1160 release date and if all the
rumors suggesting it are actually legit
but before I dive into that make sure to
hit that subscribe button if you guys
like to stay updated with the latest
tech news related to gaming and pcs so
if you guys haven't heard already there
has been some leaks that came from
Lenovo and there has been a lot of hype
surrounding the release dates of the new
1100 series and a lot of hype to the new
gtx 1180 is going to come very soon
first of all here's what happened at e3
a Lenovo salesperson was going over the
future of lenovo laptops and desktops
when he said the time to market for the
gtx 1100 series is in the fall soon
after that there was an article on
laptop media surrounding the new lenovo
legion y 530 and that it would ship with
the new gtx 1160 later this year in
November or December if this is true
then the GTS 1180 isn't actually coming
as soon as what many people thought like
in July 30th or August according to what
the salesman said a release date like in
September or October a lot more likely
with the reveal of the new leavener
series at the hot chips conference in
August this would give Nvidia a solid
two months to get rid of all their
excess ten series inventory and by the
time the new 11 series hits the market
GP pricing should be lower than MSRP so
it would make sense if these new GPUs
came in at MSRP also September and
October is right before the holiday
season of 2018 so Nvidia can boost all
their 11 or series sales because of the
holiday season by releasing in September
or October and with the release day in
September or October consumers have a
good amount of time like around two
months to decide if they want to
actually buy the 11 room series so
that's nice too and what the second
rumor is suggesting is that all the
mainstream 1100 series cards from Nvidia
would be released by November or
December because Nvidia always releases
their notebook variants after the first
three cards have been released so based
on that we can derive expected
- for each 11 or series card so what's
the 10 series the gtx ten if you launch
first and then two weeks after that the
1070 came out and a one month after that
- 1060 came out and finally one month
after that the 1080 1070 and 1062 fierce
al-khaimah on the same day later two
months after that the 1050 series was
launched and finally two months even
after that the laptop variants of that
were also launched so based on that we
can estimate the expected so based on
that we can estimate the launch
timeframe of each of eleven series cards
so starting off I'm going to assume that
the Lenovo elysian y 530 with the gtx
1160 will come out in november instead
of december biggest hideout in video or
lenovo would want to miss out on all the
holiday sales that come along with Black
Friday and Cyber Monday so if the 1100
series notebook card from invidious
launched the beginning of November then
one month before that in October at the
beginning the GTX 1160 should be
launched and one month prior to that at
the beginning of September the GTX 1170
should be launched and the gtx 1180
finally should be launched at the end of
august
so overall the gtx 1180 based on this
leak will come out at the end of august
or the beginning of September and I
think that makes perfect sense with the
reveal at hot chips so I do think this
rumor or leak makes sense so as it is
evident this leak seems very legitimate
and it makes a lot of sense but just
because it makes a lot of sense and even
if it turns out to be true it doesn't
make it a legitimate leak this could
simply just be speculation that turns
out to be true
so is this just speculation or an actual
link from Lenovo and in my opinion I
think this is all just speculation from
the salesmen biggest I doubt Lenovo orce
employees would openly break invidious
non-disclosure agreement like that
Lenovo salesperson literally gave camera
evidence of him leaking that information
I don't think that he would want that
happening this would definitely not be
okay and he would face severe
consequences for leaking embargoed
information to the public and as a
result I think
a good chance that this information
isn't actually from the lenovo
themselves and this is probably just a
salesperson presenting what he thinks is
going to happen to create more hype
around new lenovo laptops or just simply
gain more publicity also the same thing
applies with laptop media they can't
just leak information like that because
they would not only be breaking
invidious non-disclosure agreement but
probably also lenovo's I'm not quite
sure in all the details of NDA and what
the consequence is for leaking certain
things would be but gamer Nexus actually
has a full detailed 30 minute video over
invidious non-disclosure agreement where
he goes over invidious a non-disclosure
agreement with a lawyer so if you're
interested as to more details about
Nvidia non-disclosure agreement and all
the consequences now to come with it and
make sure to check out this full
detailed video on it but as far as we
are concerned here violating such a
policy would just lead to fines or maybe
the man being fired and pretty much just
bad things and because of that I don't
think these are actual leaks from Lenovo
and I think that these are just
speculations from the salesperson and
laptop media I am NOT saying if they
won't be true because I do think they
make a lot of sense and that I could
actually happen what I'm trying to say
is that this is probably not actually an
official leak so it's not asked
legitimate as many of you guys think so
just make sure to keep that in mind but
that's just what I think what do you
guys think do you guys think this is an
actual leak or is it just hyped up
speculation make sure to comment down
below what you guys think because I do
read all my comments and I'm curious as
to what you guys think so make sure to
post your thoughts also if you guys like
this video then make sure to drop a like
and hit that subscribe button if you
guys like to see more videos just like
this one but until next time bye
[Music]